parte de nuestro trabajo es el
periodístico y en ese sentido nos
encanta hacer preguntas así que hoy
creemos que queríamos comenzar con una
quiero por favor que levantéis el brazo
todos y todas las que alguna vez en una
conversación con amigos viendo el
telediario hayáis pensado o dicho una
frase como ay qué pena me dan esos
pobres negritos por favor levantan la
mano
pero christopher esta pregunta era para
pillar al público no para quedar
nosotros en evidencia a ver si ya la
semar ya si tal se perdona pero es que a
veces yo me subo al escenario y a mí me
puede la sinceridad yo no puedo mentir a
ver yo admito que más de una ocasión he
visto estas imágenes y dibujo es que
pena me da a esta gente
y de hecho también admito que más de una
ocasión estás tranquilamente viendo las
noticias comiendo y tenía alguna mala
digestión que otra porque no no es
agradable ver este tipo de imágenes en
ese momento que si vayas pateras muerte
no no no es agradable la verdad es que
pese a que es un sentimiento totalmente
natural
estoy seguro que pese a eso a más de uno
y más de una cabina venta del brazo
incluso alguno que no lo ha hecho es
porque siente cierta vergüenza en
reconocer este sentimiento y yo me
pregunto por qué será quizás es porque
lo vemos y no hacemos nada por culpa en
ese sentido o quizás por otro lado es
porque ese sentimiento de pena de
compasión a veces lo entendemos como
algo negativo pues yo creo que tiene que
ver más con lo primero que decía armario
con el sentimiento de culpa y es que
seguramente que a todos se os ha venido
a la cabeza cuando estáis viendo ese
tipo de imágenes la misma pregunta
podría estar haciendo yo algo realmente
por estas personas algo más que sentir
pena
realmente podemos hacer algo por estas
vidas bueno pues nosotros lo tenemos
claro y nosotros pensamos que sí que
siempre se puede hacer algo de hecho
nosotros hemos hecho un cortometraje
documental donde hemos dejado la pena a
un lado para preguntarnos y si les damos
una oportunidad una oportunidad para
poder integrarse y tener una vida
totalmente plena una vida con sus
ilusiones y sus sueños por cumplir
y no hace falta que todos nos montemos
en un barco de una ong para salvarlos en
medio del mar no creéis motivos me gusta
lo que comentáis pero yo también tendré
algo crisis sobre todo eso no por
supuesto sí bueno yo soy de senegal
aunque ya sé que todo lo pensaba y
quedarse en pose manchego como el queso
pero realmente soy uno de estos negritos
de lo que hablan mis compañeros
y no cree que tengan que ir a
rescatarnos cuando estamos en el mar
sino más bien cuando estamos en tierra
firme
y todos pensamos que es muy duro trágico
estos momentos en los que ya no hay nada
que perder a la deriva entre delirios
miedo y lágrimas
pero
pocos pensamos en lo que viene después
la verdad que sí porque la verdad que
normalmente en televisión o incluso en
el cine siempre nos quedamos con lo que
estábamos comentando con la primera
parte es que quizás es lo más morboso lo
que más vende pero yo os animo hace cine
contando lo que te pasa cuando cumple 18
años y te quedas en la calle en mi caso
me pasó estaba en un centro y cuando
cumplir esos años me dijeron que tenía
que ir sin tener nadie aquí en tener
familia sin conocer a nadie realmente
sabía que ese día iba a llegar porque
otros compañeros nos había pasado
gente como tú que está aquí
se preocupó por nosotros nos ayudó
y al final empezamos a aprender cosas a
valorar amigos
hacer amigos que realmente valen la pena
para poder sobrevivir y bueno yo diría
que es una experiencia que que es
difícil pero te hace aprender mucho y
gracias por christopher y armario por
darnos la oportunidad para poder contar
nuestra historia gracias a vosotros
[Aplausos]
y para nosotros es un lujo y lo es
porque nosotros creemos en el poder del
cine y por eso quería poner un ejemplo
totalmente visual un ejemplo gráfico
como veis aquí en la diapositiva en
naranja los que la vieron en azul los
que no hablamos de la película el día de
mañana una película de género
apocalíptico en el que un poco se
valoraba las consecuencias del cambio
del cambio climático como veis entre
todos los encuestados conceptos como las
inundaciones los tornados la escasez de
comida incluso una nueva era glacial
esos conceptos para ellos para los que
vieron la película siempre están por
encima de los que no la vieron es decir
una película creo una conciencia brutal
respecto al tema del cambio climático es
un ejemplo muy claro del poder que puede
tener el cine pero no sólo eso aparte de
ese ejemplo tan específico hay
muchísimos tratados hay libros escritos
ensayos que hablan de la relación entre
el cine y la sociedad realmente esta
experiencia cinematográfica uno de sus
objetivos principales es tocar la
sensibilidad del espectador
es su arma principal por eso hemos
querido poner que el cine puede ser un
arma social porque a través del cine
podemos cambiar el chip de manera
positiva podemos abrir nuestra mente
pero bueno como en todo en la vida
cuando hay una versión positiva también
hay una negativa y hay teorías también
que hablan de una influencia del cine
negativa o corruptora lo cual no tiene
ningún sentido porque realmente ni
siquiera cuando estamos bajo poder
hipnótico hacemos o decimos cosas que no
queremos toda forma de arte eso sí toda
forma de arte transmite una idea pero
claro la transmite a quien la quiere
aceptar a quien la va buscando en otras
palabras los medios de comunicación no
corrompen al hombre sino que lo
transforman coronario en otro para luego
que se ponga a ser locura
si uno arma una locura eso no tiene nada
que ver con las películas la locura ya
ya estaba ahí y es que realmente esto
del cine es tan complejo que realmente
no deberíamos hablar de cine como una
mera representación artística o como
para ganar dinero sino que yo diría que
el cine es un medio de comunicación
social
como bien decía punt man y en base a
esto los cineastas nos deberíamos
considerar más comunicadores que
artistas
y con esto no quiero decir que debamos
ir a lo simple de hecho debemos hacer
historias arriesgadas comprometidas
incluso duras pero debemos hacerlo de
una manera entretenida e incluso lo
podemos hacer divertido pero sobre todo
lo tenemos que hacer accesible para
todos los públicos totalmente de acuerdo
christopher es como si nosotros que
ahora estamos aquí en el escenario
empezáramos a usar tecnicismos un
lenguaje demasiado complejo que
conseguiríamos nos llegaríamos a nadie
de los que estáis ahí sentados en las
butacas y eso no tendría ningún sentido
al fin y al cabo el cine tiene que crear
un impacto nuestra sensibilidad y ese
impacto es lo que va a causar que cuando
estamos viviendo el cine estemos
viviendo una experiencia humana
fundamental
de hecho no es lo mismo que yo os diga
ahora mismo que la guerra es absurda a
que veamos la chaqueta metálica' igual
que no es lo mismo que hablemos de la
consecuencia de la droga a que veamos
diario de un rebelde
igual que no es lo mismo que hablemos de
los errores de la humanidad que jamás se
tiene que volver a repetir que ver el
gran dictador no la verdad que no es lo
mismo christopher todo lo que entra por
nuestros ojos todo produce ese impacto
en nuestra conciencia del que hablaba
antes un impacto en nuestra sensibilidad
y este impacto lo que va a generar es
que creemos conciencia social la
conciencia social es precisamente la
base que tenemos para que cuando veamos
un problema como por ejemplo el de gorg
y no solo lo entendamos sino que nos
emocionamos con el emocionarnos con algo
es algo más que entenderlo y eso es
importante a través de la conciencia
social de hecho todo esto lo que al
final construye es nuestra moral y
nuestra ética y estos son los dos
pilares fundamentales sin duda de
nuestra forma de ser lo que va a marcar
quiénes somos y con qué estamos
comprometidos
precisamente por eso mario le pidió a
los directores a la gente que asesine
que sigáis apostando por este cine
social y a vosotros público a consumirlo
ya que no todo es real no todo es
realidad de prisión o hollywood sino que
hay documentales y cine que dejan ver
las realidades tan duras como las que yo
he vivido la realidad es tan cercana a
las restas lejanas de realidades como la
que mucha gente como yo nos hemos jugado
la vida
muchas gracias muchas
[Aplausos]